california extends its travel ban on
state employees to red states with 105
million citizens
when barry milks her anti-american
moment for all it's worth and the
supreme court decides to leave girls
unprotected
in their locker rooms i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of by listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
ben before we get to all the news first
a quick reminder you are spending too
much money on your cell phone bill if
you have not switched over to pure talk
usa which is why so many of you
already have in fact another thousand of
you my extremely wise listeners have
already made the switch from your
overpriced wireless carrier to peer talk
over the past couple of months what
exactly are the rest of you waiting for
if you're with a t verizon or t-mobile
your family could save over 800
a year just by switching to pure talk
get the same great coverage because they
use the exact same towers as one of the
big carriers you can even keep your
phone and your number
you will save a fortune by the way
puretalk is the top-rated wireless
company by consumer affairs with the
absolute best customer service team
based right here
in america why well because they give
you exactly what you need and they're
not going to overcharge you
for it right now get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data for 30 bucks a
month
and you're saying yourself what about if
i spend like seven gigs of data what if
i do seven gigs of data well here's the
thing if you go over on the data they're
not going to charge you for it
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro to get started when you
do you save 50
off your very first month dial pound 2 5
zero
say keyword ben shapiro to get started
pure talk is simply
smarter wireless alrighty so california
has now announced
that its employees cannot travel on the
state dime
to florida and four other red states
what we are watching in the united
states is a slow motion breakup now that
does not mean
that there is going to be like a hot
civil war in which american
american citizens are shooting at each
other or firing mortars at each other or
something what it does mean
is that the states are coming apart we
have two separate countries and they are
becoming more red and more blue
respectively over time
and that is why federal politics are so
unbelievably unworkable right now
because there is just a different set of
priorities
on each side of the ledger now normally
the solution to that if you wish to
maintain a country
would be to have a small federal
government whose job it is to basically
enforce
only the most important and rudimentary
of individual rights
it would not be the job of the federal
government to get involved in each and
every decision in your life because
obviously california
lives differently than florida instead
the blue
states will not allow that to happen the
blue states wish to cram down their
lifestyle on the red states
understand that we are living in a time
of rising authoritarianism and the great
authoritarian threat is not
relegated solely to the extreme right in
fact it has taken over the mainstream
left
the mainstream left would love to
control the lives of the people who live
under its auspices they'd love to
control the federal government and cram
down those federal standards
on states that disagree with them and
decentralization
and federalism would be an excellent
solution to this but the left will not
abide that
so look at california and understand
that if you live in a red state it's not
just that california wants to separate
off from you it's that california wishes
you to live
as they live california is not merely
saying we don't want to do business with
the state of florida for example
california is saying we also would love
to run the federal government and make
sure that florida cannot act like
florida act
so here's the story from politico today
california has now added florida and
four other states to its official travel
ban list
after attorney general rob banta said on
monday the state's passed anti-lgbtq
laws that are quote unquote directly
targeting transgender youth so in other
words if you work for the state of
california
and you need to travel to florida on
business you no longer can
on the state dime because florida passed
a law saying that boys should not go in
girls locker rooms
this is how polarized our political
debate has become we've become two
countries
on nearly every issue of the day from
the most major to the most minor
and it is most true culturally speaking
now economically speaking there's a fair
bit of crossover between people who want
bigger spending programs or who want
higher taxes right there are people on
the populist right who want bigger
spending programs just directed at their
constituents and people on the left who
want the same sort of thing
economically shockingly there are
disagreements but there's more sort of
common ground for possible consensus
when it comes to economics than there is
with regard to cultural issues
which is why california is now launching
this travel ban on the basis
of laws that are supposedly quote
unquote anti-transgender when what they
are really doing
is enshrining the ability for women to
have their own locker rooms for example
the announcement which came at a press
conference on the 52nd anniversary of
the stonewall riots
means that california is now banning
state-funded travel to 17 states
based on a 2016 law banta announced that
arkansas montana north dakota and west
virginia
have now joined florida as the newest
states on the list bonsai said
california must take action to avoid
supporting or financing discrimination
against lesbian gay bisexual and
transgender people now if california
wished to take this to its logical
extreme
california would stop investing in any
company that does business in these
states you'd get full-scale
boycott and divestment from companies
that exist in these other states maybe
tariffs against
those other states right which of course
would violate the privileges and
immunities clause of the united states
constitution which leaves all of this in
federal hands
five years ago california prohibited
most taxpayer-funded travel to states
deemed to have passed laws that
discriminate against lgbtq people
assembly bill 1887 was prompted by an
outrage in california over a north
carolina law that required people to use
public bathrooms based on the sex shown
on their birth certificate
now you may ask yourself what exactly
does california have to say about that
that's the whole point
california doesn't merely wish to live
as california wishes to live california
wishes north carolina to do what it
wants or there will be consequences
you notice that north carolina has not
banned traveled to california florida
has not been traveled to california
the discrimination and the
authoritarianism only run one way
before bonsai's announcement on monday
12 other states were already on the
california ban list
alabama idaho iowa kansas kentucky
mississippi north carolina oklahoma
south carolina south dakota tennessee
and texas you may notice something that
these states have in common
they're all red the law has limited
exemptions such as travel necessary to
enforce california laws participate in
litigation
or protect public health college teams
are now forced to use private funding
in order to travel to these states to
participate in athletic competition
that's if ucla wants to play university
of alabama well then they have to
somehow
get private donations in order to travel
the human rights campaign has been
pushing this the human rights campaign
is a radical
pro-lgbtq group they say that 2021 has
been a record-breaking year for
anti-lgbtq and anti-transgender
legislation okay
understand the legislation that is being
passed is not anti-lgbtq
it's not anti-transgender it protects
women who are biologically women
end of story but again california has
been
engaged in this battle against red
states for quite a while and you know
what's happening
red citizens in blue states are just
leaving they are realizing
that the next target is going to be them
they are realizing as i realized with my
family
that we didn't just move because of the
taxes from california we moved from
california to florida because
we don't want to live under the purview
of
authoritarian small-minded bigots who
believe that religious lifestyles need
to be banned
in order to facilitate the great social
left-wing movement
which is what is going to happen in
california if you believe that the sort
of discrimination they are now
attempting to to push down on oklahoma
and north carolina
and florida doesn't apply to their
citizens within their own borders you
got another think coming
assembly member evan lowe democrat of
campbell chair of the california
legislative lgbtq caucus said it's
important for our state to send a strong
message
he said the list expansion also sends a
message to state workers they will not
be required to travel to states
discriminating against lgbtq and trans
youth
where our opponents are motivated by
fear and hate
is the country is pretty obviously
coming apart at the seams we are engaged
in what i will call a cold civil war but
it's not a hot civil war because again
nobody's firing guns at each other
but it is a cold civil war and it is a
cold civil war
only because the federal government has
not been able to
actually use its power to cram down
california
on florida and that's going to be the
great battle of the future
there's a sort of bumper sticker that's
been going around in florida
because governor ron desantis is very
popular here florida has gotten a lot
redder even it has gotten
demographically browner which is kind of
an amazing rebuttal to the left-wing
notion that demographics are destiny
so there's this bumper sticker that's
been going around which is make america
florida there's another one going around
don't california my florida
well if america were more like florida
what that would mean is that
californians get to live
as they wish to live it would also mean
that floridians get to live as they wish
to live
if florida would become more like
california that would because
the federal government is cramming down
a particular set of standards and
practices on floridians that they do not
want
only one direction is this authoritarian
i saw yesterday that there are a lot of
people on the left who are
bizarrely surprised at the fact that
clarence thomas the most conservative
justice on the supreme court
had made statements about how the
federal government really should not be
in the business of regulating marijuana
i'm not sure why they're so surprised by
that that's been clarence thomas's
position for quite a while
i'm not sure why there are so many
people surprised by this
national review has been in favor of
decriminalizing marijuana use for
decades at this point why
because if you are on the right one of
the things that you rely upon to
maintain the ability to live
a liberty driven lifestyle is more
libertarian perspective on government
the left does not have any such
compunction the left deeply desires to
cram down its own world view on
everybody else so understand
when we talk about a cold civil war this
is not an even-handed civil war in which
both sides
want similar things from the other side
very much the opposite
the right typically wants to be left
alone and the left does not want to
leave the right alone
and you can see this you can see the
country coming apart on every
major and minor issue of the day
particularly on social issues if you see
the map getting more polarized that is
because the social left has been on the
march it's not the economic left
yes obamacare made a difference but
obamacare was not the great breaking
point in the united states the great
breaking point in the united states
was the recapitulation of american
politics in terms of radical
social policy that alienated the entire
middle of the country
and it continues to pace so when the
when the left says why are you paying
attention to social issues the answer is
because we see what you are coming to do
we see what you want from us okay so to
take an example
now let's talk about the issue of race
in the united states okay so
in order for us to live in a common
polity
we have to understand certain
basic agreements right even if you
believe in a sort of federalist
perspective a libertarian perspective
there have to be certain basic premises
which is that we all share a country for
a reason and that the country
is rooted in some fundamental good if
you believe that the country is
fundamentally bad and wrong and it needs
to be completely remade
particularly along authoritarian lines
well that is going to lead to conflict
well half the country cheers that second
perspective at this point
right which is why you see gwen berry
making national news we now live in a
country where you become more rich and
more famous for boycotting the national
anthem
than you do for simply standing up for
the national anthem in baseball in the
1970s there's this very famous
circumstance where rick monday was an
outfielder at the time for the chicago
cubs
it was a wrigley field and rick monday
went and uh and grabbed a there was a
guy trying to he ran out of the field he
was trying to burn american flag rick
monday came over and
grabbed the american flag away from him
and he was cheered for this today
the player himself would be lighting the
american flag on fire in the outfield
and the media would be cheering
for him so gwen berry has made
international headlines because at the
olympic trials she decided
to turn her face away from the flag and
to make faces during the national anthem
and then to post about
what a courageous fighter she was the
reason why we are all paying attention
to you gwenberry is because you want us
to pay attention to you
you want the attention the quick path to
fame and riches in the united states is
to
crap all over the flag not to pay
attention to the flag being patriotic
is considered rote and hackneyed
burning the flag is considered forward
thinking and wonderful by at least half
the country which means there can't be
any sort of unified polity there have to
be some things that we agree on
on a broad level and by the way if
you're if you're representing the united
states in for example the pan american
games as gwen berry did right she she
did in 2019
and she got in hot water with the
international
olympic committee the united states
olympic committee specifically because
she decided that she was going to
raise her fist during the national
anthem in protest of something or other
and um and then the new york times gave
her space right because that is how this
works so she's been attempting to get
attention for this sort of stuff for for
quite a while
despite the fact that gwenberry has
lived a pretty amazing life in the
united states as it turns out
wenberry grew up in her grandparents
home there were 13 people in the home
in her grandmother's home and then she
had a baby out of wedlock at the age of
15.
got a scholarship to go to southern
illinois university
and she's made a career ever since
throwing a hammer that's kind of an
amazing thing in the united states
you don't hear a lot of stories like
that in other places but the utter
ingratitude
is the point so here is gwen berry
speaking to the new york times
it's just about a year ago talking about
how cruel it was that people were angry
at her for protesting the american flag
and the national anthem again while
voluntarily joining a team to represent
the united states we're not talking
about
a regular even colin kaepernick playing
for an nfl team and deciding he doesn't
like the national anthem like adult
we're talking about somebody whose overt
job is to represent the united states
and we're supposed to cheer them when
they crap all over the united states
and the new york times thinks that this
is great here was gwenberry talking
about this just last year
so last summer at the pan american games
i threw 74 meters and i won gold
i remember the medal was so heavy and so
real i was excited
i was nervous
[Music]
in that moment when the national anthem
was playing
i knew that that national anthem did not
speak for people like me
in america the freedom liberty and
justice for all
is not for black people something came
over me
i raised my fist
i felt like i was not at peace with
myself if i had not said something or
did something in that moment okay
let's point out something she says that
the national anthem and the flag are not
for her she is literally sitting there
wearing a shirt that says united states
pan american team with the american flag
on it
weird weird how you're very happy to
take the notoriety associated with
representing the united states
and then to crap all over the national
anthem and the american flag
but this has become mainstream thinking
on the left okay they they cannot offend
people
who wish to tear away any common symbol
of the united states
again i'm all for diversity of viewpoint
she has a right to protest she does
she doesn't have a right to to protest
while representing the united states
per se because it's a weird thing it's
like as charles cook of the national
review suggested
it's like saying that you're going to
play for the new york yankees you get
signed by the new york yankees you
signed the contract and the first thing
you say is i'm never wearing pinstripes
i'm only wearing a red uniform
like well no that's not how any of this
works but in the united states
free country she can say whatever she
wants if we are to have a common polity
however there has to be certain basic
agreements on certain things like you
don't get to invade
you know other people's individual
rights so her rights are not being
invaded also we should have a baseline
level of social agreement
that there are some common symbols that
carry some sort of sacred unity
representing those rights
but we don't want to unify over all that
so you have jen saki from the white
house defending this sort of stuff
i haven't spoken to the president
specifically about this but i know he's
incredibly proud
to be an american and has great respect
for the anthem and all that it
represents especially for
our men and women serving in uniform all
around the world
he would also say of course that part of
that pride in our country
means recognizing there are moments
where we are as a country haven't lived
up to our highest ideals
and it means respecting the right of
people granted to them in the
constitution to peacefully protest
well of course we respect the right of
people to peacefully protest it doesn't
mean you're not an idiot
depending on how you protest but again
this is gwenberry knows
what the math is here she knows that
she's gonna get rich and famous off of
this nobody heard of her yesterday
everybody's heard of her today
it's that simple an unhealthy country is
one that celebrates people
who spend their day tearing down the
country while purportedly representing
the country
that is not a particularly good thing
all these cultural issues matter
they do especially because the kind of
idea that america is inherently bad will
be crammed down on your kids right it's
not as though this is a
a everybody has their own perspective
game
people in the united states government
right now in the educational system wish
to push
you to believe all the same sort of
stuff they wish to teach the 16-19
project in schools
they wish your kids to be indoctrinated
in this sort of
nonsense ideology in college
corporations mirror this sort of stuff
right that is a dangerous thing in the
united states
because this is a battle for power it is
and
it turns out the people who respect the
american flag the most are also the ones
who are basically going to be okay
with people in the private sphere doing
what exactly
wenberry does and again i'm fine with
that on a basic kind of
descent level but the people who do what
gwen berry does in control of power are
going to be very intolerant of anybody
having a pro-america viewpoint there's a
bit of a zero-sum game
going on here we'll get some more of
this with regard to race in just
one second first let us talk about the
simple fact
that right now you need to know what's
going on on your property there are a
thousand reasons why protecting my home
matters to me if somebody stops by or
something is going on outdoors around my
house
ring will let me know it's peace of mind
anytime knowing my home is protected
at my house i can keep an eye on every
corner of the house with a ring it's
easy to install indoor and outdoor cams
to get ring alarm for yourself
go to ring.com ben it is the perfect way
to start your ring
experience besides ring being a powerful
asset for my home ring is also an
affordable whole home security system
you can easily install yourself
it's never been more important to be
able to see who's there or what's
happening anytime around the house
inside or outside
i see it all in one simple app that's
right with ring my family and i can keep
an eye on our home no matter where we
are right from our phone
it's great to know you're never gonna
miss a visitor with rings hassle-free
easy to install indoor and outdoor cams
and know when those packages are
delivered start protecting your home
today with ring alarm
go to ring.com ben get your ring alarm
security kit today
you can build the system that's right
for your home and have it up and running
in just minutes that is ring.com
once more ring.com again that is
ring.com
and go check out the ring alarm security
kit today we use it at our house to make
sure that our kids are safe and secure
you will end up doing the same check
them out right now ring.com
ben okay so it is not just gwenberry and
her
silly idiocy with regard to protesting
the national anthem while representing
the united states that is indicative of
the cultural battle we find ourselves in
is the fact that again institutions of
power agree with gwen berry
institutions of power are cramming down
their notions of america as an evil
country
on the rest of the country which is why
you have princeton university declaring
itself racist
and now boasting that their new class is
68 people of color
after waiving their sat score
requirement according to daily wire
chrissy clark reporting at the ivy
league institution announced in april it
admitted almost 1500 students for the
class of 2025 a full 22 percent of
admitted students are first-generation
college students
68 self-identify as quote-unquote people
of color
now the problem is that this to them is
the only metric as to whether they have
done something good or bad
in order to achieve 68 people of color
apparently they had to get rid
of all of their objective metrics
of academic performance the record
number of racial minority admittees
comes after the school removed its
standardized testing requirement citing
a quote-unquote lack of access to
testing sites
students were allowed to submit their
standardized test scores although they
allegedly played
a limited role in the admissions process
it is not a coincidence that
that literally the year you got rid of
all the standardized testing suddenly 68
percent of the incoming class is
minority
i still want to know how many of those
people are asian because according to
the admissions officials asians don't
count as minorities for purposes of
college admissions
but the the zero-sum game that is a
college admission slot
you know how that gets how that gets put
out yeah how it gets filled
is largely dependent on whether you
believe in individual rights and
individual performance or whether you
believe
in quote-unquote social justice and
group thing
and it is pretty clear that the
institutions of our society have decided
once again
to cram down on the american people
particular perceptions
of how things should work and this is
happening at the federal government
level too
right this is why you have the federal
department of justice now telling
georgia
that it cannot construct its voting laws
how georgia wishes to construct its
voting laws
and calling them racist in the process
again this is all part and parcel of the
left attempting to seize the commanding
heights of power in authoritarian
fashion
and shut down opposition meanwhile
claiming that it's the right trying to
shut down opposition
there is a difference in kind between
the department of justice for example
attempting to shut down georgia's voting
laws and people criticizing
with no real effect gwen berry not the
same thing at
all okay and yet that is exactly what
the department of justice
is doing the department of justice is
now suing georgia the georgia attorney
general and him christopher carrie says
this is blatantly political which of
course it is
this is just a blatantly political
lawsuit but i've said it's not a lawsuit
it's a campaign flyer the department of
justice
is simply playing politics they are not
upholding
the rule of law and and this blatantly
political action
taken by the united states department of
justice
is factually legally and
constitutionally wrong
anybody who will actually read the
georgia law
sees it strengthens security it expands
access
and it improves transparency and that's
why we will be successful
defending this uh particular action as
we will the other seven
okay and uh again what this is
indicative of is that we are two
countries
in terms of our our mentality with
regard to race
on the one side we have people who
believe that race is a is a
characteristic that really ought make no
difference in how we treat people
individually on the other side there's a
group of people who believe race is the
only important thing in how we treat
people both individually and
institutionally
and the people on the second side wish
to militarize all the weapons of the
united states government and our
institutional culture
in order to cram down that point of view
on everyone who disagrees
that is just one indicator of our
cultural civil war
okay meanwhile another part of our
cultural civil war remains sexual
politics
so remember we have one half of the
country that believes with regard to
race and this sort of racially radical
viewpoint that we get to cram down on
you
social justice woke prescriptions for
inequality of outcome
another group of people who say let's
hold true to certain founding ideals
that everybody ought to be treated
as an individual as the declaration of
independence suggests
and then when it comes to sexual
politics there's a group of people who
say
that unless you abide by our sexual
standards
we are going to shut it down unless you
abide by our sexual standards we are
going to use the power of the government
to shut you down
it's it's a new woke puritanism and it
is indicated by the
again state of california banning travel
to states that do not think like the
state of california does
that men can be women and women can be
men and now you have the greatest
institutions of our society
promoting this idea right down to the
most minor institutions in our society
promoting
the ideals of sexual liberationism from
the 1960s
as the new dominant culture okay when it
comes
so for example the supreme court just
refused to take a case refused to take a
case
with regard to whether a trans student
must be allowed to use the opposite sex
bathroom
so you have a boy who says he's a girl
can he now use the girl's bathroom
thanks to justice gorsuch and his
ridiculous decision in bostock
thanks to that particularly idiotic
decision which suggested the civil
rights act of 1964
somehow magically covers people who
believe they are members of the other
sex which is just an absurdity on its
face
i mean it's an uncertainty on its face
because of that
the supreme court has now declined to
take up whether or not women are allowed
to have separate spaces
whether women can for example have their
own locker rooms free of a male walking
in
and dangling his junk half the country
thinks it is absolutely unthinkable
you should have any regulations
protecting biological women whether it
is in sports whether it is in locker
rooms or
whether it is in any other area of
american life and the predictable effect
of this of course
is discrimination against women and now
there's a case to be made again on a
libertarian level that if you a private
business
owner want to have single sex bathrooms
or if you want to have these policies in
your locker room
then you can have those policies in your
locker room you know free
freedom for all but there is very little
case that you should be able to use the
commanding
heights of institutional and cultural
power in order to leverage
americans who disagree with you into
being discriminated against in places
that they frequent
which is exactly what is happening right
take for example what is going on in la
right you want to know why exactly there
are people in florida who are worried
about social issues in l.a it's because
they know that california would like to
extend the dominance of this ideology
into florida
and so for example this is a a locker
room
controversy at a spa in la in los
angeles
uh there's a los angeles spa it's called
the wii spa
and an outraged woman in a biological
woman
who happens to be minority apparently
she walks up to the desk and she says
i'm in there with young little girls in
the spa and there's a man walking around
with his junk hanging out
and the spot insists that this is no
problem because of course the man
identifies as a woman here's a little
bit of the video
i just want to be clear with you it's
okay
it's okay for a man to go into the
women's section
show his penis around the other women
young little girls
under age your spa we spa
condone that is that what you're saying
like
i asked it's so he can stay there
he could stay there what sexual
orientation i see
it lets me know he's a man he he's a man
okay but there's an entire wing of
american public life that says not only
is he not a man this woman is a bigot
for saying that a man walking around a
spa with his junk hanging out
is a woman right if you say that that
that
man is not a woman you are the bigot
she's the bigot
i mean these are social issues that have
dramatic ramifications because it is
coming for you it is coming for your
business it is coming for your religious
life it is coming for your school
the left has made this absolutely
apparent and not just
on the governmental level right using
anti-discrimination laws
in order to cram down this bizarre
version of human logic in which men can
become women and women can become
men an unprecedented notion in all of
human logic or history or biology
or physics or any other field of human
endeavor it is
institutions who have socially taken up
the cause because they understand that
the left is pushing for control
and the right has been back footed on
this stuff they've been wrong-footed for
years and years and years the right has
been told
you know why are you focusing on those
social issues if you just leave the
social issues off the table because
that's the contentious stuff
then focusing on economics that's where
you guys are going to win you're going
to win supporters when it comes to lower
taxes and lower spending
it is precisely the opposite if you look
at the trump coalition the trump
coalition was largely rooted in cultural
concerns
not in economic concerns and those
cultural concerns grow more grave every
single day
because there is one group that is on
the march and one group that simply
seeks to preserve
its own perspective on life which
happens to be rooted in reality and
biology and natural law
again people on the right are not making
the case per se
that a private business in los angeles
doesn't have the ability
to have single sex locker rooms they're
saying you don't get to leverage that
idea on me
the left has no such limitations on its
own ambitions here
and the cultural institutions of our day
are seeking to cram down values that
have literally nothing to do
with their core businesses on everybody
else remember
we don't just live in a governmental
sphere or laws and regulations we live
in a cultural sphere so it does make a
difference what your kids watch on tv
it does make a difference when major
corporations are attempting to leverage
down
on your kids when you walk into a target
and fruit loops is selling
gay pride month paraphernalia to your
five-year-old
right and that's what it's directed at
well that has an impact on how your kid
thinks
and to pretend that it doesn't is to
ignore what time it is
it is to ignore what is going on in the
world okay the the this is why parents
are attempting to guard their children
it's why parents are saying
you know we just want to be left alone
but you will not leave us alone
and by the way if forced to it it falls
to the confrontation the cold civil war
that is currently happening
will continue to heat up there will just
be a struggle for who gets to control
everybody else there will not be any
broad-based agreement on classical
liberalism where you get to do what
what you want to do and i get to do what
i want to do if the left push is too
hard they're not going to get classical
liberals in response
they're going to get people on the right
who react by saying okay well we will
take
control of the commanding heights and
now we will use our leverage to press
our own political viewpoint into law
we will attempt to cram down on you what
it is that we want
not even on a state or local level we
want
and not even with regard to public
funded enterprise we'll do with regard
to private funded enterprise
they are the left's radicalism and and
deep
willingness to renormalize institutions
to weaponize against people they don't
like
is going to result in a backlash that is
going to be far uglier than what the
left thinks is going to happen next
and it does come down to things like
what you see in your daily life pissing
you off right it does come down to
things like
the nfl for example putting out
full-scale commercials saying football
is gay
okay now let's be real about this
football is football it's not gay
it's not straight football is just
football the hell does the nfl have to
say about sexual politics
when you turn on a game typically it's
because you wish to watch people
play football not because you wish to
watch the nfl
socially message about any particular
social issue whether you're talking
about hands up don't shoot which was a
lie or whether you're talking about
homosexuality and politics
and yet this is what the nfl is pushing
because they feel the cultural momentum
from the left what they don't understand
is sooner or later there's going to be a
backlash and it's going to be quite ugly
against a lot of the same institutions
that have been renormalized on behalf of
radicals
most americans have been apathetic about
these sorts of issues the harder the
left pushes
the more the backlash is going to be the
greater the backlash is the more
polarized the country becomes
there is no apathetic middle anymore you
will not be allowed to be apathetic
you will not be allowed to say things
like i don't care what the nfl sexual
politics is i just want to watch
football
that in and of itself will be evident of
your discriminatory nature
here's the nfl ad
it says football is gay
hmm interesting football is lesbian
football is beautiful football is queer
it's life's exciting it's transgender
it's bisexual
football is freedom football is american
football is accepting
football is everything well it isn't
football is everything for everyone
except
if you happen not to believe in the
morality of particular sexual behavior
if you believe in traditional natural
law morality with regard to sac football
is apparently not for you
if you believe in going to church and
you actually read the bible apparently
football is not for you
when they say football is for everyone
they mean everyone will be forced to
agree with us and then football will be
for everyone in the same way that joe
biden suggested that he was going to
pursue a new unity and i said at the
time does he mean unity
while acknowledging the the possibility
that people disagree with him or does he
mean unity and that he is going to cram
down a unified agenda on everyone
regardless of whether they agree and it
became pretty obvious pretty clearly
and pretty fast that he meant the latter
right okay and and you can see it all of
this is manifesting in every area of
american life simultaneously
every area of american life has become
polarized in our new cold civil war
we'll get some more of that in just one
second
first let us talk about a simple fact
if you need a great night's sleep you
really need a personalized mattress you
can't just go down to the big box
mattress store you lie in the mattress
for two seconds you're like oh this is
the one for me
and then six weeks later you're creaking
because the bed is just
hurting you and it's terrible instead
why not get a mattress made just for you
check out helix sleep helix sleep has a
quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep
everybody is unique helix knows that
they have several different mattress
models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your doorship for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by both gq and wired
magazine just go to helixsleep.com
take their two minutes leave quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights at risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you absolutely will helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pills for
our listeners
at helixsleep.com ben right now again
that's helixsleep.com
right now go check them out and again
you get 200 bucks off your mattress
order
when you do alrighty in just one second
we'll get to more
on our polarized cold civil war first
if you're looking for an excellent
historical documentary that gives you an
in-depth and uncensored look into the
life of an american hero
i have excellent news for you the daily
wire read your mind we've added created
equal to our cue
the film tells the story of supreme
court justice clarence thomas the most
important justice of the last
half-century
and his journey from the segregated
south to the highest court in the land
and the attempts of the left
to destroy him and then to essentially
say that he never existed
the documentary is only available to
daily wire members if you want more
stories that diverge from the accepted
political narrative head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe get 20 off your new membership
with code justice
as you'll recall amazon decided it would
be an excellent time to get rid of the
film
last february in the middle of black
history month of course which makes
perfect sense since clarus thomas is um
the second black american to be on the
supreme court and the first conservative
black american but
the daily wire has now made the
documentary available for you you should
go check it out
right now it's great your kids should
watch it it's available to members at
dailywire.com if you're not yet a daily
wear member join now
at dailywire.com subscribe with
codejustice for 20
off your membership and get ready for a
film unlike any other once you remember
be sure to check out all of our other
excellent content we've got candace with
candace owens
our first film run hide fight or my new
series debunks where i debunk leftist
myths in 15 minutes or less
and get all of that and more on demand
by going to dailywire.com
subscribe check out with 20 off using
code justice
don't wait start streaming today also
make sure that
if you are watching this on youtube you
like and subscribe and hit that little
notification bell that one is really
really important because otherwise
you're not going to be notified when a
new video
pops up go check us out on youtube as
well you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
america isn't just coming apart around
very contentious issues
like sexual behavior or race
america is coming apart around issues
that theoretically should be apolitical
i mean the simple fact of the matter is
that covid should have been a very a
political space right it is a basic
health issue
and it should have been apolitical it
quickly became political and it became
political
because opposing donald trump became a
sign of absolute virtue
and this continues today to the point
where people are just delusional
i mean it's absolutely wild and you you
have a poll out today
okay and the poll shows that 57 percent
of republicans think the pandemic is
over
compared to four percent of democrats
four percent of democrats now the answer
to whether the pentagon is over is
whether it is over for you
if you are vaccinated the pandemic is
over okay if you are 20 the pandemic
was never really a thing that you had to
worry about too much because you were 20
and you weren't going to die
okay if you were 65 or over the pandemic
remains a thing if you are unvaccinated
it is not a thing
if you are vaccinated in other words if
what you mean is
should the united states be engaging in
broad-based public policy rooted in the
notion
that this pandemic represents a threat
to the american way of life
absolutely not we are past that everyone
every adult in the united states all the
way down to teenagers has now had the
ability and the opportunity to get a
vaccine if you don't get a vaccine that
one's on you
so is the pandemic over the answer on a
public policy level is pretty obviously
yes
okay but democrats four percent of
democrats think it's over
four percent four okay as opposed to 57
percent of republicans
why did it break down this way and the
answer is there's a group of people in
the united states who largely populate
the coast who believe
that they feel more secure in the
swaddling blanket of a government that
tells them what to do
this is why the right is worried guys
because you who are very comfortable
with the swaddling blankets of
government don't just wish to swaddle
yourselves in that blanket you wish to
mandate that everybody else
swaddle in the blanket as well you wish
to mandate that your level
of comfort and and social acceptability
be promoted by government and
corporations that's what you want
people on the right yeah i've always
been a little bit bewildered by the fact
that there's some people on the right
who are deeply upset when people
continue to wear masks if you want to
wear a mask that's your problem if
you're suggesting
that you are more virtuous because
you're wearing a mask now you're just
being an idiot
okay because the reality is if you're
mass and you're outdoors and you're
vaccinated you're like a triple idiot
okay so first thanks for getting the
vaccine also you shouldn't be masked
anywhere let alone outdoors let alone
thinking you're more virtuous for doing
all those things
okay and yet the left has full scale
embraced all of this
the left continues to embrace the idea
that the swaddling blankets of
government are not only necessary but
you should be mandated to follow what
the government tells you to do
even after you've had the opportunity to
get the vaccine now
i'm a big fan of vaccines i'm not
objecting to public schools suggesting
that kids have to have
mmr vaccines before they go to school i
get it because the reality is that the
deadliness of mmr
is fairly significant for children and
not only that it is highly contagious
i get all of that and yet we have this
notion now that kovit ought to be
treated the same way that mmr is
okay that's ridiculous especially
because unlike
measles mumps rubella pertussis for
example unlike
those particular diseases the vaccines
with regard to covet are so unbelievably
effective that once you have had the
vaccine
your chances of dying from kovid are
basically nil
i mean we're talking like
infinitesimally small
and yet four percent of democrats think
that the the pandemic is over the rest
of democrats still think not only that
the pandemic is on but presumably that
it's a public policy issue
over the span of the pandemic according
to newsweek more republicans than
democrats have questioned the
seriousness of the covenanting virus
likely following the lead of former
president donald trump but this of
course is the point
okay all the stats were available from
the very beginning we read you stat on
stat
day on day i mean we took the pandemic
very seriously here on the show
i would read you the death statistics
every day i read the infection
statistics every day
i would read you infection fatality rate
every day which differentiated from the
case fatality right because a lot of
cases were not in fact
being diagnosed we talked with
scientists we talked to epidemiologists
we talked to doctors we talked to all
those people throughout the show
you were getting the best information
you are if you listen to the show
and we were very realistic about what
the risks were and how they
differentiated based on pre-existing
health condition and age
so when i say that everyone's had the
opportunity to get the vaccine
understand this is not coming from
somebody who never believed that coveted
was a threat we were very clear
on what covett was and to whom it was a
threat
four percent and not only four percent
they want
the cram down that's the key you want to
live in a bubble the rest of your life
that would be your problem except it is
not just your problem you are making an
everyone's problem
in the same way at the left with regard
to sexual politics if you want as an
adult to identify as a member of the
opposite sex
you can do whatever you want it's a free
country you don't have the ability to
cram down on me what i ought to think of
you
because that's a violation of free
thought and free speech and free
association
but you can live however you want and
bear the consequences of that but it's
not enough
right the idea is that if i want to live
in a certain way everybody has to live
in that way like this is the
authoritarian left at work
i have a book the authoritarian moment
about the renormalization of america's
institutions
on this basis that is what we are
watching and it's particularly obvious
when it comes to covid because you can
see people weaponizing the government
against people who disagree
again what's amazing about that is that
joe biden has been saying basically the
pandemic is over
right joe biden can't even buy it back
it's too late for joe biden he tried to
buy it back
he kept saying the pandemic was still on
and now when the pandemic is pretty
clearly over for the vast majority of
the united states except for some
unvaccinated areas where again
it's over in the sense that it's your
job to get a vaccine if you don't want
it you're a problem now
people still refuse to accept it's
unreal and so for example
you have the specter of los angeles
county health department
saying that everyone regardless of
vaccination status
should mask up in indoor public spaces
right now
right now in la hey two weeks
ago california lifted its mass mandate
for vaccinated people in accordance with
the cdc guidelines
and the vaunted cdc but now la county
is saying no no because of the delta
variant we want you to re-mask up in
public places
i mean this is insanity people are
addicted to government control they like
the government control why
because it allows for the possibility
that you are going
to be able to control other people
you are a virtuous person because you
are now one of the
the government's choice associates and
you get to
cram down on everybody else things that
the allure of power
is pretty striking by the way how many
cases were diagnosed what is this here's
the seven day average
the seven day average of la county okay
the the population
of l.a county at last count is 10
million people
okay that is the population of valley
county the the seven day running average
of diagnosed coven 19 cases according to
the new york times
is 243 out of 10
million people 10 million people okay at
the height of this thing in l.a county
like in december
you're getting seven day rolling
averages of 14
15 000 cases a day you're down to 243
cases
the lowest essentially since the
beginning of the pandemic and yet l.a
counts he's like you know what delta
variant mask up again
and people love it they want it because
in the end they don't just want to
control themselves you can control
yourself easily just put an ask into
what you want
you want to control other people this is
why the new york times is a piece by
aaron carroll suggesting it's time for
the united states to now
engage in vaccine mandates it doesn't
matter the vaccines are extraordinarily
effective
and that once you have been vaccinated
you pretty much don't have to worry
whether anybody else has
it is your business now dr carroll is
the chief health officer for indiana
university
and he says that now it's time to create
a stick
to compel people to get the vaccine now
again i'm a huge fan of the vaccine
but the notion here is that the
government gets to cram down on you
whether or not to get a vaccine that
again if you get it insures you and if
you don't is your problem
is pretty wild and does come down to an
ideology of control
says dr carroll the mrna vaccines made
by modern and physical bioentech will
likely get full approval for use from
the fda soon which may be necessary for
broader vaccine mandates
although the vaccines are already known
to be safe and effective after being
given to hundreds of millions of people
with full approval more groups will
begin mandating their employees get
vaccinated it's unlikely the united
states can overcome the pandemic without
such actions really
it's unlikely that we can overcome the
pandemic without such actions very
strange
because i am looking at the united
states coveted numbers
as of like right now okay the number of
new cases diagnosed in the united states
yesterday was six
thousand seven hundred and seventy one
in a population of three
hundred and thirty million people
we didn't have mandates so what the hell
happened
again it is it is astonishing the level
to which people not only
want to exercise control but control
others
okay the the the country when we say
that the country is
now engaged in a great split this is
what we mean
and the split is not even handed there
are people who want to live how they
want and then there are people who want
to control how other people live
and this is completely reversed the
left's case in the 1960s is that these
evil right-wing theocrats wanted to
control what you did in your bedroom and
what kind of drugs you took
and how you lived your life the the
people who are now interested in
controlling every aspect of your life
how your workplace is whom you associate
with
what kind of church you go to how your
children are raised
whether you ought to be a parent or not
these people exist on the left
and they wish to cram down that vision
on everybody else and the more they cram
it down
again i keep saying it but it's real the
harsher the blowback's going to be the
response is not going to be the
classically liberal response of
everybody go his own way wave your fist
unless he hit somebody else in the face
the
response is going to be if you insist on
grabbing that gun i will grab the gun
from you and i will use it against you
that will be the response and it will be
quite ugly okay and
that does bring us to a fairly
incredible story so tucker carlson
mentioned last night on his show that a
whistleblower at the nsa is saying that
the federal government
is now spying on him now i've noticed
that the media are very upset
when republicans spy on democrats as
well they should be they seem
far less upset when when tucker carlson
is uh is targeted apparently by the nsa
i mean the very least wouldn't this
require further investigation here with
tucker last night
but it's not just political protesters
the government is spying on yesterday we
heard from a whistleblower within the us
government
who reached out to warn us at the nsa
the national security agency
is monitoring our electronic
communications and is planning to leak
them
in an attempt to take this show off the
air now that's a shocking claim and
ordinarily we'd be skeptical of it is
illegal for the nsa to spy on american
citizens it's a crime it's not a third
world country
things like that should not happen in
america but unfortunately they do
happen and in this case they did happen
okay so should there be a congressional
investigation on that of course and
should there be bipartisan support for
the notion that the nsa doesn't get to
spy on political opponents of course
i have a feeling the left which is which
is very very upset
at any criticism of left-wing
journalists so threats to journalism as
a whole
uh we'll see how many of them are
actually interested or concerned
about all of this even if it turns out
that tucker is absolutely right alrighty
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content coming up
soon
is the matte wall show it airs at 1 30
pm eastern be sure to check it out over
at dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pablo wydowski
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events
all the fundamentals if they matter to
you come check out the show
you